behind the smiles there's mounting
pressure on these allies to do more to
arm Ukraine
Germany's defense minister in particular
will be feeling the strain
and perhaps an unspoken sense of
disappointment
there'd been hope Berlin would allow
german-made tanks to join the war but
that's not yet been decided despite this
plea from the president
gentlemen this is a Time remains a
rational weapon
we have to speed up time must become our
common weapon just like air defense and
artillery armored vehicles and tanks
Ukraine says it needs some 300 modern
tanks to help break through Russian
lines
but so far only the UK has stepped up
with just 14 of its Challenger 2 main
battle tanks
what Ukraine is really after are these
german-made leopard two tanks which are
far greater in Supply with around 2 000
operated by multiple European countries
it makes them easier to support and
maintain if sent to Ukraine
Poland has offered to supply some of its
leopard tanks but it needs Germany's
approval
any move by the U.S to send its Abram
tanks could finally convince Berlin to
follow suit but there's no sign of that
for now
wattington and Berlin have agreed to
supply dozens of armored fighting
Vehicles like these American Bradleys
they'll also be critical if Ukraine is
to stand a chance of defeating Russian
forces something the U.S military Chief
warned won't happen anytime soon
this year it would be very very
difficult to militarily eject the
Russian forces from all every inch of
Ukrainian occupied or Russian occupied
Ukraine that doesn't mean it can't
happen doesn't mean it won't happen but
it'd be very very difficult
challenge no doubt made Harder by
Germany's indecision over its tanks
just responsibility for our population
in Germany and in Europe and we have to
balance all the pros and contracts
before DBZ we decide things like that
just like that
until that happens and the answer is yes
leopard tanks across Europe must stay
locked out of Ukraine debraham Sky News